drôle d'endroit pour une rencontre il ne
s'agit pas de studio de télévision mais
d'un parking c'est là que vous vous
rencontrer catherine deneuve gérard
depardieu dans ce film qui sort demain
et qui est signée par françois dupeyron
un film dont vous êtes heureux
l'un et l'autre oui oui globalement oui
très heureux en ce qui me concerne et je
ne dirait pas le contraire non plus
alors on est presque déjà d'orvault dans
la lenteur de vos réponses dans
l'ambiance de ce film à zemmour en filou
très étrange et je vous propose d'en
voir un extrait un parking au bord de
l'autoroute une femme que l'on jette un
homme qui bien sûr c'est le début du
film n'en veut pas
baa
sur la poule longtemps j'ai perdu plein
femme se confirme dans la poule la poule
de luxe
alors c'est un film étrange parce qu'on
dirait presque du théâtre unité de lieu
unité d'action unité de temps c'est ça
qu'il voulait attirer l'un et l'autre
dans ce scénario
gera oui ma faim ce qui m'a intéressé
c'est de voir d'abord c'est de voir un
drôle de couple
enfin un rôle de femme et puis par la
même occasion un couple
derrière c'est vrai que le théâtre aussi
j'aime j'adore le théâtre et puis je
trouvais que c'était difficile de rendre
une autoroute de essayé de parler de
l'intimité sur des gens qui parce qu'ils
traversent
voilà moi c'est ce qui aurait pu
m'arrêter parce que j'ai jamais fait de
théâtre et c'est quelque chose que je
redoute beaucoup mais en même temps je
rêvais règle quand j'ai lu le scénario
c'est ce qui m'a beaucoup fatigué dans
l'histoire c'était ces deux personnages
épinglé la nuit cet homme qui allait
repousser cette femme longtemps d'avoir
parce qu'une femme qui s'est jetée comme
ça dans un an quand on est seul on a
décidé de s'attaquer à une chose
concrète qui est le moteur sa voiture
c'est ça fait désordre et puis ça vous
empêche de travailler ces brefs et cet
homme va être très résistant d'ailleurs
la présence de cette femme mais ce qui
me plaisait surtout c'était je crois à
l'idée de m'affronter avec avec gérard
dans la même direction c'est à dire de
s'engager dans quelque chose je savais
que j'aurais besoin de lui je savais que
j'aurais pu que je pourrai l'aider qu'on
allait avoir un vrai tête à tête parce
que j'ai mal j'ai tourné plusieurs fois
avec lui on a eu des très belles scènes
mais on n'a jamais tourné aussi
longuement ensemble
alors justement on sent dans ce film une
extraordinaire complicité entre vous qui
est presque plus une complicité je
dirais de deux coffres de stature plus
que de tempérament alors c'est vrai
c'est votre cinquième film ensemble
c'est parce que vous ne connaissez bien
ou pas ce que vous
mérité l'autre d'une certaine manière la
mission de mérite humain mais je sais
que moi j'ai l'impression qu'on est
assez complémentaire
même physiquement je dire
physiologiquement comme ça je trouve que
quand on nous voit ensemble à l'écran il
ya quelque chose de complémentaire
non pas qu'il soit fort et que moi je
sois fragile mais gérard à l'adresse
l'avait plus fort c'est plus oui c'est
plus souterrain que ça mais disons que a
priori à l'avant-première premières
impressions oui et après moi j'ai les
brutalités ou des brusqueries comme ça
que gérer un nappage aura une voie
beaucoup plus douce avec des inflexions
beaucoup plus douce que moi moi je peux
être même sèche parfois et je trouve que
ça fait une musique un peu différente
je n'arrivais à vrai couple comme ça sur
au cinéma ou même dans la vie des gens
dans la vie de retour dans la vie c'est
difficile d'aller au cinéma c'est très
rare alors justement cinq films déjà
ensemble et vous êtes vous est consacré
le couple mythique du cinéma français
donc ça veut dire que pour notre plus
grand bonheur à tous vous allez
continuer longtemps et plusieurs fois ça
ce sera la réalité du jugement final
qu'il décidera mais enfin c'est vrai que
c'est très agréable de se retrouver sur
un sur un film comme celui là avec des
rouleaux s'y déroulent aussi fort et
puis des tournages de nuit c'est très
particulier comment bien vieux pas
tellement de fabriquer que l'on a envie
de partager quelque chose au cinéma
c'est vrai et le couple mythique vous
vous trouvez bien assortis moi je crois
que groupe mythique reine ne pas parler
ne pas se montrer ne pas venir à la
télévision et se voir sur les écrans et
puis ne plus depuis apparaître les
couples mythiques sauf que c'est des
choses qui donnerait bien longtemps
après tu meurs vécu plein l'idée de a
priori de faire rêver sur une image du
couple qui en plus une image sont assez
moderne et assez réalistes même très
cruel c'est une idée qui me plaît
beaucoup
en tout cas je le dis tout net vous êtes
l'un et l'autre éblouissant dans ce film
donc drôle d'endroit pour une rencontre
un film qui sort demain très vite